foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
well in that case what are we drinking
same for the goddaughter God told me you
found something on a train during the
war a dial that could change the course
of history why are you chasing the thing
that drove your father crazy
he'll move please get out of here
sorry
Dr Jones get him
[Music]
Hitler made mistakes and with this I
will correct them all you stole it then
you stole it and then I stole it it's
called capitalism
foreign
[Music]
and now a final Triumph
Indiana Jones a few times in my life
we're seeing things
I'm gonna torture with Voodoo
big shot nine times
included once by your father
ah sorry
but I've been looking for this
all my life
[Music]
I want things to say the way they are
stop time Monday whether you like it or
not
[Music]
he was flying a little bug did it
I think that's a bug
she is a fairy are you Peter Pan were
you expecting someone else
Neverland is this everything you dreamed
of I could never dreamed of this
where is this place no rules no schools
no bedtimes and most of all no growing
up are you Wendy
Captain it's Peter Pop
ever say
his name
[Music]
don't touch my brother
miss me just like old times all your
times are old captain
[Music]
[Applause]
to grow up might just be just be the
biggest Adventurer of all
the Demeter
on Charter from Romania to London
shipping private crates
intense unknown
out at Sea with no land in sight
this year's comments he's a doctor
we dress like a learned man University
of Cambridge I'm on my way around the
boat our Charter has agreed to pay a
bonus for timely arrival in London
let me show you the ship this here is
huckleberry
we don't come with like this to give the
US clear
[Applause]
something right about the animals
on the livestock this looks like a bite
search the ship
everywhere
evil isn't bored
[Music]
powerful evil
in night it rings our blood he is here
we call him Dracula
he's coming
see the size of that bloody thing
[Music]
he is on this ship which piece we will
never leave the devil is real
may God have mercy on us all
foreign
what the hell are you doing
entering the jump Point perimeter
I'm gonna get you some readings Fury
hello Monica hello
[Music]
is this an Avengers
where's Captain Rambo
[Music]
[Applause]
okay so our powers are entangled I can
manipulate light energy and you I could
totally show you
again
hi where's our doctor wherever you were
[Applause]
[Music]
a team no no no we're not we're not a
team
[Music]
born here
raised here
the storm is the only World you've ever
known
as a place just off past the Eastern
Ridge
right there dad what are you talking
about you'll see
get out there
to the crater
whatever's out there your dad wants you
to see it we've never even been outside
the Dome before
so what's it going to be we're leaving
tonight are you
I hear you why
so the peculiar you're peculiar all in
favor
let's go steal her over
the lockdown will commence
you know the best thing about road trips
everything behind
here it is bottom of the knife the wind
up
thank you
this guy on Earth isn't really blue yeah
this is a bad idea
[Music]
it's not just about where you're going
run it's about how you get there
the people you get there with Caleb
what's in the crater I don't know
guess we'll find out you guys go first
quite the same as you were when you
[Music]
hi Barbie
hi Ken
hey Barbie hi Barbie hi Barbie hi Barbie
hi Barbie hi Barbie
hi Ken
hi Ken now
[Music]
I thought I might stay over tonight why
because we're a girlfriend boyfriend
to do what
I'm actually not sure
[Music]
okay ladies let's do this
[Applause]
[Music]
yourself
[Applause]
I'm coming with you
[Music]
did you bring your rollerblades
I literally go nowhere without them
oh looks like this beach was a little
too much Beach for you Ken if I wasn't
severely injured I would beat you off
right now Ken I'll beat you up with you
any day Ken anyone who wants to beat him
up has to beat me off first I will beat
both of you off at the same time beats
both of us off nobody's gonna beat
anyone off
[Music]
my name is Miles Morales I'm Brooklyn's
one and only Spiderman and things are
going great oh yeah you're supposed to
be here all right whatever whatever wow
whatever so are you like a cow or a
Dalmatian I am the spot
it's not funny
don't do that
grades are pretty good A and AP Physics
that's my little man and a B in Spanish
that's why
to you and I think you know it
[Music]
wanna get out of here oh when
so wait a minute there's an elite crew
with all the best spider people in it
who's the new guy danger this is
unbelievable this is the lobby
Miguel O'Hara the whole thing with his
idea
what's the guy gotta do to join this
spider team you can never be part of
this don't even get me started on Doctor
Strange and a little nerd back on Earth
1999.99 come on go easy on the kid he
had a terrible teacher Peter you have a
baby
I'll take it from here
miles being Spider-Man is a sacrifice
you have a choice between saving one
person
and saving every world
ah send me home I can't do that I can do
both Spider-Man always always what about
Uncle Ben if not for Uncle Ben most of
us wouldn't be here
[Music]
you know
there's no idea what are you doing
everyone he's telling me how my story is
supposed to go nah
I'm gonna do my own thing
[Music]
and then I looked at my uh let me guess
he died
excuse me Mr Reyes
he finished scraping the gum off that
lounger or what all right
everything right now feels so Out Of
Reach you always land on your feet bro
you're hymen
I just wanna rap Johnny
but do not open it you went in to get us
jobs and all you brought back was the
hamburger
okay I don't think it's a burger you
haven't looked
what the hell is that
how did you get it to do that
likes me
[Applause]
almost acquired okay
all right
oh
re-entry systems ready
what is going on
it's called this character it's some
kind of world destroying weapons it's
designed to protect the toast
sometimes it does what you want and
sometimes it doesn't
I think I cut a bus in half
Scarab chose you but it belongs to me
hello you feel for your family
makes you weak
[Music]
the universe has sent you a gift and you
have to figure out what you're going to
do with it
whatever you can imagine
I can create
[Music]
I
behind whoa It's like Batman stuff
Batman's a fascist
[Music]
why am I here Roman I need you we're
gonna destroy their own nuclear program
you know the risk trust me
okay
oh my God
pencils just came through the cia's
targets an Iranian nuclear facilities
our cover is born we leave for 15
minutes
stretching point
[Music]
to go home and
if the distance is not the main issue
that's what's in between
any of them catch my guy will sell them
to the highest bidder there will be no
Sanctuary for you
raise your hands
do it before they get Trigger Happy
names
please believe me
tell me what's truly going on
we're cut outs in an even bigger game
this is my life in your hands
no one is coming to rescue us
sorry
for everything
[Music]
last night I had a dream about who first
met
[Applause]
we were criminals friends and then we
became Guardians
this is the end of the road let's make
it count
on May 5th I will destroy the Guardians
Time to Say Goodbye
summer begins it's a Face-Off
their final tour I guess we'll die
trying
I know who you are already recordings of
the Galaxy Vol 3. are you ready
I was eight years old when I left there
you want me to drive no I'll drive
figure out how to put it in backwards
it's on sale now
[Applause]
will you read us a bedtime story okay
three little kittens with Fleur all
brushed said we can't sleep we feel too
rushed wow this is garbage do you
actually like this illumination the
studio that brought you Despicable Me
The Secret Life of pets
I feel heroic and handsome
a little wet but I still look good the
Grinch
You're a Mean One mister
sing
you okay
oh yes I'm fine thank you
how are you minions
[Applause]
and the Super Mario Brothers movie
there's a huge Universe out there
this Christmas illumination brings you a
film for the entire family
here we go for the torsion check Wing
deployment
let's fly
migration
We're not gonna make it early Uncle Dan
have you seen the group chat I'm doing
it again tonight
huh no please that's my mom's
Remembrance Day I just want to forget
about it huh
[Music]
[Applause]
I'll do it
cannot go for more than 90 seconds am I
clear what happens after 90 seconds
don't want to stay
foreign
blow it out to close it
put your hand on it
now say
talk to me
[Applause]
[Music]
talk to me
what did the hand feel like
felt amazing I could see and feel
everything on the other side
so my mom she was trying to reach out
here
still been saying stuff you've been
saying stuff
what if we open the door but we didn't
shut it
oh my God
I like it I'm not gonna stop you're
never gonna stop
I like you
[Music]
it's very pretty
that type of girl you're attracted to
I am so sorry
daddy passed down to you but I wanted a
child
I'm visiting my mother tomorrow
do you ever wish that she was dead what
oh are you on your way
I'm on my way I just I think is it
I sincerely talking
I'm sure you'll do the right thing
sweetheart
the patient has lost the ability to
speak he's not deaf and he's technically
not new with the proper amount of care
it's possible that he could regain his
understanding of the world his ability
to speak what's our first course of
action well the state is not going to
pay for any of that so we are going to
put his ass on the first bus downtown
[Music]
get in
take a look at this guy what about him
he's a dead ringer for you it's man
don't look nothing like me I mean look
at him he's too short you can finish the
day for you
excuse me Mr Pronto can I call you latte
latte Pronto latte Toronto is that your
name you and me are gonna do big things
pal and respect bro move stars coming
through
welcome to your team you got me your
agent got your manager lawyer publicist
personal assistant plus we got you an
intern
you have got a big film Premiere
tomorrow night does that make you a
little bit nervous
this was a gift from Prince Harry it was
one of the original Knights of the Round
Table sword or something
I can't really remember because I wasn't
listening when he gave it to me
is not ringing don't worry bill I'll get
this back on top I know you think what's
been happening to your careers
accidental everything is by Design
who are you really latte pronto
[Music]
and toy time
I'll get down big time
Sean God
perhaps you can help him looking for my
son Roy and Quinn your son y'all waiting
for somebody yeah it shouldn't be too
long I don't like I'm checking this out
[Music]
either way
falling down get up against the wall
where are we going I need you to wait in
here can anyone please tell me where my
son is being kept
stay quiet and we'll get out of this
together
I thought I wanted to clean operation
and I suggest you give me that phone
call
I assure you he was here with an FBI
agent a sensible drawing Senator boys I
could find them
easy first assignment yeah easy my ass
Alice my partner's dead
take the back stairs down to the boiling
room yeah
let's go through a past life we got some
help on the inside Captain Michelle
Miller Purple Heart three-time Gold Star
let's do everything we can to help that
Soldier
you're searching for Ryan and they are
not gonna stop
Ryan this family's going down whether
you like it or not agreement she was
just going to hand Ryan back she's
working for the feds
once
where's my brother
what is this so now commence reading
aloud The Book of the Dead
[Applause]
thank you
mom
open up now
we can be a big happy family again you
don't look so good mom
laughs
no dead rise tickets on sale now
so it's the last day of the bones of
rally
thank you I'm gonna be the champion
I just wanna race
a silk road rally oh it's gonna be epic
building a trophy case I mean you
haven't even won yet but I will you seem
pretty confident you're gonna win
willing to stick a bet on it you're the
one who's supposed to be going to be
doing the beating of me
I laugh at the idea
[Laughter]
why the long face kid kinda have to sort
of race the Silk Road Rally that race is
no holds bar 200 miles per hour for four
days to raid across unforgiving terrain
against the craziest drivers in the
world
I know how am I gonna beat the best
racer in the world all right kid listen
everything you need but you and me
together
there ain't nothing we can't do
whoa okay let's see what you got let's
go
do you see that guy's car if I had a car
like that cars don't win races
[Music]
I'm in way over my head I can help you
but no questions asked you would do that
but why okay there was two questions
right off the line see you tomorrow
hello reached the home of the retired
and gifted where are you I'm in a church
what are you serious we're looking for a
venue for the wedding you're going to
get married in a church I'm shocked you
didn't burst into flames as you cross
the threshold
to live in Arthur oh thank you I think
we should all go to Italy Italy whoa
we'll make it bib's Bachelorette a
bachelorette what are we doing I think
it's very romantic but it's also nuts
[Music]
got it
joining us tonight
four random women show up this is it
is room for random beautiful women
Gianni who is Tiana what are you doing
here this is my cookie School wow I'm
here to start animals Bush I think
somebody's bush is already quite amused
it's two Bridals it's not Bridal enough
gorgeous someone else next
what are you doing that would be me
we're best friends for 50 years and you
married marriage my solo act is finally
coming to a close you're the bravest
person I know the only question is how
will we mess this all up I can't wait to
find out
is it too soon to talk about who we're
gonna eat first I think we all know hey
how does a woman in her 70s end up
getting married
it takes control of her own destiny
this is the bachelorette party no that
means we go see naked men
what's the protocol here where do I
stuff the dollar bills
Ella when are you and Aiden gonna have
kids I look at the one kids
why don't you want kids well you want
kids the family is everything I have a
family don't worry your clock will kick
in I mean what do you do all day without
kids
foreign
times I'm happy with or without kids I
really wish I believed them there's a
couple of Empty Chairs at the table Dad
can we not
don't want
I never have I actually don't have a
clock all women have a biological clock
maybe yours is just
broken
new biotech firm doing a clinical trial
this month can get you in
[Music]
it is the singular evolutionary goal of
a species to procreate that is our
purpose we administer a newly engineered
synthetic hormone pair that with
cognitive behavioral therapy and the
option of an implant
deep breath
that might be a tough case you're not a
case to me Ella you're a human being and
the best kind too what kind is that a
woman
oh
you want kids today we'll be learning to
perform maintenance the family is
everything on a working clock
to reset the car I am out of time
[Music]
out of time working clock
shut up
[Music]
foreign
okay thank you
[__] game come on man
[Music]
thank you